you're in way better shape than i am
what's this right now what's that what
i'm doing
okay so me personally i i'm about like
comfort and feeling like without if i
gain too much weight i'm
focused too much on just building muscle
and not caring about just
and you could get bigger by just eating
everything you know i mean but to
if you want to feel good and gain muscle
strength stress
i'm learning that stretching helps and
then but
food is like 80 of your like how you're
gonna feel
okay you know what i mean so i what i'm
trying to do now is i'm gonna eat
as much vegetable if you eat a a
stir-fried pan of
just broccoli that's that has protein in
it
i mean that i'm eating uh uh two they
have these new tuna fish uh
packets uh-huh and you tear them open
and mix some
like chop up some pickles and a lot and
if i eat like two or three packs of that
tuna fish that's me personally
consistently drinking water so you get
that pump you feel good
dr water vegetables low carb high
protein
a lot of water it sounds it's it's it's
like cliche because that's
obvious but when you really when you
repeatedly just do that do that do that
for days
you start waking up with more energy and
you want to work out more
you feel so once you can get to that
stage where you actually want to work
out more and you realize oh
it's like putting gas in your car you
don't put a take a snickers bar and
smash it into your gas tank
it has to be gas it has to be pure gas
you can't [ __ ] throw some corn nuts
and no it's like oh well there's a wait
go tear some
[ __ ] hawaiian punched green kind let
me see what this does
yeah yeah you can't do that it has to be
gas so like your
body is just like it requires a certain
thing
and right now what i'm starting to do is
be like okay if we were
100 years ago you know ac just got
invented recently you know what i mean
like
process processed food where i go if it
didn't if
if i was i think if i was a caveman was
this around
so fruits vegetables you know what i
mean pistachios almonds
you know what i mean even like meat like
i i tried not to eat meat because i'm
just like
it had to be a a caveman looking at like
a lion tearing
tearing apart a deer and being like i
guess i'll try that right somebody's
eating if they're eating it if that lion
is strong and he's eating that
then i should have been so imagine that
caveman walking up and taking a chunk
out of that
fly-ridden [ __ ] deer and that ain't
you know what i mean
then you have to add fire and like but
imagine being
way back in the day and then you find a
[ __ ] kiwi
you're like what the [ __ ] is this
tarantula butt yeah you [ __ ]
slice it open you're eating that imagine
and that tastes good to us today
yeah so imagine like back in there like
yeah okay this is these are like these
are
[ __ ] hidden gems yeah and they have
vitamins and fruits and it's
real you know what i'm saying so i'm
trying to like be on like fruits
and so you're thinking of things that
are real things that somebody could find
if they're high
if they're back in the day they could
find yeah and i think that's what we're
supposed to eat
i think there's hidden like [ __ ]
clues in the world and you just have to
find them but if you're too focused on
some [ __ ]
then you aren't gonna be thinking like
that like you're putting the [ __ ] in you
yeah it's how you feel it's how you
think it's how you see it's how you you
know i mean
do you think your diet affects the way
that you think hell yeah
if you aren't in a good mood and if you
physically like imagine you're hungover
if you're hungover you can't think about
what how your dog feels you can't think
about how your friends feel how you're
if you have a girlfriend why you can't
think about that you're like oh just
[ __ ] make me feel better i need to
feel better you're
like you know i mean you're you're
you're think you're thinking inward
yeah when you can when you think clear
and you're that's why i want to
when you work out early in the morning
blood flowing and blood gets your brain
like okay
i'm ready for the day i'm good yeah you
know what i mean you get that blood
flowing and you get
thinking clearly then you give off a
whole different radiation
yeah yeah i'm trying and that's what i'm
going towards i'm not there yet i'm just
i take little bits of pieces that
everybody i see or that everybody does
and then i'm like you can't do
everything that somebody says no and i
don't want to give advice to somebody
but i can tell you what i'm doing right
now yeah and i'm
that's what i'm in right now yeah your
experience yeah you can only share your
experience
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be
so far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
blown